[Applause]
craig's seeing his first minutes of the
night defensively here for phoenix
george throws it inside man lays it up
and in
man wanted a whistle as well there
seemed to be some contact
then it's back to a three-point game
under a minute to play
and mighty williams will use one of his
two timeouts left
it looked like terence man got hit gets
inside
no question about it he did get the
bucket but
not the whistle phoenix up three
with the ball when we come back second
count
prouder looking charge has it
lost it momentarily picked up by payne
dribbles out of trouble
and he's zack zarba makes the call ball
deflected
they wasted way too much time in fouling
and they had
saric who had caught it
they had the perfect guy to try to foul
right there
that might have been off of paint i'm
surprised they're not looking at that
and that's what the clipper bench is
trying to make them aware of and
they don't travel looks to inbound
finds chris paul and chris paul fouled
immediately with seven seconds remaining
see to me that was the same exact thing
that happened in game two
the same type of play and i bet you it's
closer to
going off of the dribbler like it did go
off
absolutely you're 100 correct
[Applause]
see the ball and it looks there on that
but off